how is money created
where does it come from
who benefits and what purpose does it
serve as a money system what is the
money behind the money system
for centuries the mechanics of the
monetary system have remained hidden and
the prying eyes of the populace
yet its impact both on a national and
international level
is perhaps unsurpassed
for it is the monetary system that
provides the foundations for
international dominance and National
control
today as these very foundations are
being shaken by crises the need for open
and honest Dialogue on the future of the
monetary system has never been greater
this economic crisis is like a cancer if
you just wait and wait thinking this is
going to go away just like a cancer is
going to grow and it's going to be too
late what I would say to everybody is
get prepared
there's another time right now to
wishful thinking the government is going
to sort things out the governments don't
rule the world Goldman Sachs rules the
world
we're on the verge of The Perfect Storm
lie corrupt and entrenched interests
that lurk in the corridors of power
for whom there are no reasons to
relinquish privileges they feel are
justly deserved
has he got
from plan for the NH
[Applause]
of the deficit
[Applause]
do you trust the government
foreign
[Applause]
there's no coincidence that booman boss
started to become a real cyclical issue
around about the 1700s when William
Patterson founded the bank of England
this is a terrible Behavior as far as
the public no it's not funny
only in your mind is it funny it's not
funny at all it's disgraceful
the system is inherently unstable as a
result of the international power it
provides to the dominant parties
for at the heart of it lies the idea of
how can I get something for nothing
statistical analysis has found that
every time an Empire begins to near its
own demise you'll find that its currency
will be debased there is no guide to how
this whole system operates to give you
an example a researcher at the BBC
working on the Robert Pest and
documentary went to the bank of England
and said can you give me a you know a
guide to how money is created
and they just said no
this documentary will investigate and
explain this ever-changing system
and the impact it has both on a national
and international level
[Music]
foreign
in 2010 the total UK money supply stood
at 2.15 trillion pounds
2.6 percent of this total was physical
cash
53.5 billion
the rest 2.1 trillion or 97.4 percent of
the total money supply was Commercial
Bank money
the three percent of money
um is created uh through the central
bank and that money essentially if you
created a 10 pound note you could sell
that to a bank to put into their ATM and
the bank would have to repay that 10
pound or buy it for 10 pounds there'd be
no interest charged on that money but
that money is then essentially
transferred to the treasury and it's a
it's a it's a form of fundraising for
the government it's called synerg
[Music]
when the bank of England creates a 10
pound note it costed about three or four
Pence to actually print that note and it
sells it to the High Street banks at
face value so at 10 pounds and
The Profit the difference between
painting the note and actually selling
it for 10 pounds
goes directly to the treasury so in
effect all the profit that we get on
creating
physical money banknotes goes to the
treasury and it reduces how much taxes
we have to pay
over the last 10 years that's raised
about 18 billion pounds
in 1948 notes and coins constituted 17
of the total money supply
this was one contributing factor in the
government's ability to finance post-war
reconstruction
this included the establishment of the
NHS
in only 60 years notes and coins have
shrunk to less than three percent
yeah
prior to 1844 banknotes were created by
private Banks and the government did not
profit from their creation
pre-industrialization there was multiple
forms of money coexisting and so the
kind of Rise of kind of of government
sponsored Fiat money is a relatively
recent
phenomenon in the 1840s there was no law
to stop Banks from creating their own
banknotes so they used to issue paper
notes as as kind of a representative of
what you had in the bank account instead
of you taking your heavy metal coins out
of the bank and they're going and paying
somebody with them you could get your
paper which said how much money you had
in the bank you could give that to
somebody and they could use that to go
and get the heavy metal coins from the
bank now over time these paper notes
became
as good as money people would use the
paper notes instead of going and getting
the real money from the bank and
obviously as soon as the banks realized
that
what they were creating had become you
know the dominant type of money in the
economy they realized that by by
creating more of it they could generate
profits you know they can just print up
some new notes lend it and get the
interest on top of that and they did
that you know up until the 1840s in the
1840s they pushed it just a little bit
too far and that caused inflation it
destabilize the economy so in 1844 the
conservative government of Robert peel
actually passed a law
that took the power to create money away
from the commercial Banks and brought it
back to the state so since then the bank
of England has been the only
organization authorized to to create
paper notes
since then everything's gone digital and
what we now use as money is the digital
numbers that commercial Banks can create
out of nothing
[Music]
the problem was
that they did not include in that in
that legislation the deposits the demand
deposits held in banks by individuals or
electronic forms of money which
essentially what those demand deposits
are today most of the money in
circulation is is electronic money and
it's bank it's Bank demand deposits that
just that sit in our in our account so
in a way the legislation has got needs
to catch up with developments in in
electronic money and the way that Banks
actually operate
money held in bank accounts are called
demand deposits
this is an accounting term the banks use
when they create credit
Banks follow the same process when they
create loans
all money held in bank accounts is an
accounting entry
[Music]
the reality is now that most money is
not paper and it's not metal coins it's
digital it's just numbers in a computer
system you know it's your Visa debit
card it's your electronic you know ATM
card
um it's this it's plastic you know it's
numbers in a computer system you move
money from one computer system to
another it's all a big database and this
digital money is what we're now using to
make payments with it's what we actually
use to run the economy I think a lot of
people in the UK probably think that the
government or the central bank
is is in control of most most money in
circulation and Issues new money into
circulation but that's not the case it's
private banks that create the vast
majority of new money in circulation and
also decide how it's allocated
the official terminology for this
accounting entry is Commercial Bank
money
when Banks issue loans to the public
they create new Commercial Bank money
when a customer repays a loan Commercial
Bank money is destroyed
the banks keep the interest as profit
there's a lot of misconceptions about
the way Banks work there is a a poll
done by the Cobden Center where they
asked people you know how how they
thought Banks actually operated around
30 percent of the public think that when
you put your money into the bank it just
stays there and it's safe and you can
understand why because you know every
every child has a piggy bank where you
keep putting money in and then when it's
a rainy day you smash it and you take
that money out and you spend it so a lot
of people keep this this idea of banking
you know it's somewhere safe to keep
your money so that it's there for
whenever you need it
um another the other 60 of people assume
that when you put your money in that
money is then being moved across to
somebody who wants to borrow it so you
have a pensioner who keeps saving money
on her entire life and then her life
savings have been lent to some you know
young people who want to buy a house but
actually Banks don't work like that
at the moment in the UK money creation
and control is is largely in the hands
of private Banks uh about 97 to 98 of
money that's that's created is is
created as Bank Bank debt money you
could call it when Banks issue money
into circulation as as loans essentially
this is very poorly understood fact
it's not a conspiracy theory it's not a
it's not a crackpot Theory it's the way
the bank of England describes the
process when Banks make loans they
create new money
a few economists will realize the way
the money system works but if you don't
if you don't realize the way that money
works and you think that you know
everybody's saving is going to work well
for the economy what really happens once
you understand the way the money system
works is that if everybody starts saving
the amount of money in the economy
shrinks and we have a recession so most
economists don't have this this full
picture they don't understand all
elements of the system they rely on
assumptions on you know receive
knowledge without actually going into
the details and you know money is money
as a center of the economy if you don't
understand where it comes from who it
creates who creates it and when it gets
created then how can you understand the
entire economy
when the vast majority of money that we
use now is not cash but it's electronic
money then whoever's creating the
electronic money is getting the proceeds
of creating that money and obviously
creating electronic money is much more
profitable than creating cash because
you don't have any production costs at
all so while we've got 18 billion over
the course of a decade in profit from
creating cash
the banks have actually created 1.2
trillion pounds
between 1998 and 2007 the UK money
supply tripled
1.2 trillion pounds was created by Banks
whilst 18 billion pounds was created by
the treasury
a lot of people think when I say this or
when you say this or when positive money
say this that we're all just a bunch of
Nutters but on the 9th of March in 2009
the government of the Federal Reserve
Ben Bernanke gave the first ever
broadcast interview the governor of the
Central Bank of the United States of
America never given and the day before
that he bailed out AIG
um which is a insurance company not even
a bank actually to the tune of about 160
billion dollars so the journalist system
now Mr Bernanke where did you get 160
billion dollars to bail out AIG just
First Bank so it's lent to a bank we see
recently use the computer to mark up the
size of the accounts they have with the
Fed so it's much more Akin
as to borrowing
[Music]
Banks create new money whenever they
extend credit buy existing assets or
make payments on their own account which
mostly involves expanding their assets
when a bank buys Securities such as a
corporate or Government Bond it adds the
bond to its assets and increases the
company's Bank deposits by the
corresponding amount
[Music]
new Commercial Bank money enter
circulation when people spend the credit
that has been granted to them by Banks
that I found that talking on the
doorstep from August last year around to
August 2009 round two
the general election or eight nine eight
nine months I suppose knocking on doors
is that when you try to explain how the
money system works
there's uh an almost inbuilt refusal of
people to accept that such a bizarre
situation could actually exist
no you can't possibly you know thanks
don't create money out of thin air
that's ridiculous they can't do that
they lend out their deposit is money
most people have an idea of how money is
they're used to their own way of
handling money
and they try and Implement their own
idea of how how their small household
economy works
into the national economy and of course
it just doesn't work out it just doesn't
work out at all
by 2008 the outstanding loan portfolio
of Bank created credit also known as
Commercial Bank money
stood it over two trillion pounds
as recently as 1982 the ratio of notes
and coins to bank deposits was 1 to 12.
by 2010 the ratio had risen to 1 to 37.
that is for every pound of Treasury
created money
there was 37 pounds of Bank created
money
in the 10 years prior to the 2007 crisis
the UK Commercial Bank money supply
expanded by between seven to ten percent
every year
a growth rate of seven percent is the
equivalent of doubling the money supply
every 10 years
the amount of money they're creating out
of nothing is just incredible 1.2
trillion in the last 10 years and
there's that money has been distributed
according to the priorities of the
banking sector you know not the
priorities of society
Bank sector
itself grew from 1980 2.5 trillion
dollars
to 40 trillion dollars by assets in 1980
global bank assets were worth 20 times
the then global economy
by 2006 they were worth 75 times
according to the U.N
as the following chart shows total Bank
assets of UK Banks as a percentage of
GDP remain relatively stable at 50 to 60
percent up to the end of the 1960s
after that they shot up dramatically and
the real money in in the world to be
made today is not by producing anything
at all it's simply by forms of
speculating basically making money from
money that's the most profitable and and
by far in a way
um the the biggest form of of activity
of economic activity that exists in the
world today
today
banks are no longer restricted by how
much they can lend
and as such how much new credit they can
create out of nothing
they are restricted solely by their own
willingness to lend
the issue worth allowing Banks to create
money there's two main issues firstly
the fact that they create this money
when they make loans so it guarantees
that you know we have to borrow all our
money for the economy from the banks
as such to have a healthy growing
economy the government needs to put in
place strategies to allow for ever
increasing debt
the only way the government can create
additional purchasing power is by
getting itself and us into more depth
the second big issue with allowing Banks
to create money
is that they have the incentive to
always create more you know they create
more money if they issue a loan they get
the bonuses and the commissions and the
incentives to create you know to lend as
much as possible you have to develop a
sales culture what did they do they
recruited an amazing guy lovely guy Andy
Hornby who came from Asda to turn the
bank into a supermarket retailing
operation if you trust Bankers to
control the money supply the money
supply will just grow and grow and grow
as will the level of debt until a point
where it crashes you know when some
people can't repay the debt and then
they'll stop Lending
you hear politicians and journalists
saying you know we've we've been living
beyond our means we've become dependent
on debt we need to reign in our spending
and live within our means
um it's not possible in the current
system you know
the reason why I've reducing debt now is
not because they've been recklessly
boring we haven't borrowed all this
money from you know an army of
pensioners who've been saving up their
whole whole lives money in the current
system is debt you know it's created
when Banks make loans so the only way in
the current system that we can have any
money in the economy you know the only
way we can have money for business to
trade is if we borrowed it all from the
banks
and it's the very opposite of what the
Tory parties arguing today which is that
you have to create savings before you
can help the National Health Service and
it's because economists have completely
confused those things both in monetary
policy terms but also in economic
thinking and because most people still
Harbor the old-fashioned view that you
need savings before you can invest
that we have the mess that we're in
today now one of the reasons why we find
it difficult to understand the banking
system and credit creation is that we
leave school without any money
and we go and get a job working as an
apprentice to a plumber we work really
hard all month at the end of the month
somebody puts money in our bank and so
for us the logic is you work and then
you get money you get Savings in reality
you would never have got that job if
credit hadn't been created in the first
instance it's a really important
um
conceptual misunderstanding
and it isn't something that the public
just are guilty of economists don't
understand this stuff money doesn't come
out of economic activity
a lot of people have come across as kind
of assume that if you've got people if
you've got businesses and you've got
people doing things that somehow money
somehow
emerges out of the process of people
doing things doing economic making
things and growing things and selling
things and producing things that somehow
money just emerges
it's not it's like oil in the car you
have to put it in when I see David
Cameron talking about how we need an
economy not based on debt but we need an
Economy based on savings he just doesn't
know what he's saying it's ridiculous
it's absolutely absurd and it shows his
complete lack of understanding of how
our money system actually works what
he's essentially saying is that we need
an economy with no money if everyone was
saving we'd have mass disappearing of
money which is essentially what a bank
write-off is essentially is people
defaulting on their debt which which
essentially is just money disappearing
but if people weren't taking on the debt
then it's just it's just such a joke
it's such a a amateur understanding of
how our economy works and how the
monetary system works and how money is
actually created so I really do get a
laugh out of watching what people are
actually saying and they're all just
regurgitating what they've learned off
each other and you just hear the same
things and it just makes me it it really
gets on my nerves when I hear people
talking about
um yeah we need more regulations we need
to regulate the way banks are actually
and the bonus it's all just one big
smoke screen and working on all the
symptoms of a greater disease which is
really you need to look at the the money
system the way money is created and I if
we don't want any debt then we're
essentially saying we don't want any
money and we want a moneyless economy
with the exception of the three percent
that's created debt free
you know it's a paradox under the
current system if you if we as the
public go into further debt then that's
going to put more money into the economy
and we're going to have a boom when you
have a boom it's easier to borrow so
people get into even more debt and
eventually you know this this cycle
continues it gets easier and easier to
get into debt until some people get over
in debt and then you know they default
they can't repay their mortgage that's
what happened then you know it happened
first in subprime America
um and then you know that just brings to
a wave of defaults which will Ripple
across the entire economy
the banks go insolvement then we're into
a financial crisis
and then the bank stopped landing and
you know they were excessively Landing
in the boom and then they stopped
landing and then that Court makes the
recession even worse people lose their
jobs and then they become even more
dependent on debt just to survive
basically you know we have a system
where we have to borrow in order to have
an economy we have to be in doubt to the
banks
and that that guarantees you know a
massive profit for the banks
this is the boom bust cycle
set before Mr Deputy speaker no return
to boom and bus
[Music]
netbank lending must forever increase
we're paying interest on every single
pound even if even if you think the
money belongs to you
somebody somewhere is paying interest on
that money the banking system has such a
huge impact on the world
but only because it supplies our
nation's money supply
we have to protect them we have to
subsidize them we have to allow them to
continue because the the disaster of of
a bank collapse affects us all in a huge
way and anyone that says that we
shouldn't have bailed out the banks
doesn't quite understand the the nature
of our monetary system that's like
eliminating a huge chunk of our money
but also bailing out the banks is
perpetuating a system which is never
going to work anyway so whatever we do
we're always going to have this cycle
until we separate how money is created
and the activities are banking then the
banks can do as they wish they're a
normal business like everyone else
there's a major Democratic issue here as
well I mean you have these private
profit-seeking Banks creating up to 200
billion pounds a year and pumping that
into the economy wherever they want
basically wherever it suits them whether
they're pumping it into you know these
toxic derivatives or putting money into
housing bubbles just making housing more
expensive 200 billion pounds in 2007 of
new money coming into the economy
created out of nothing and where that
gets spent determines you know the shape
of our economy effectively so if we're
going to allow anybody to create new
money out of nothing and we should at
least have some democratic control over
how that money is used I mean it would
we rather have had that money used for
health care you know to deal with some
of the environmental issues to reduce
poverty or would you rather have it to
make houses more expensive so that none
of us can afford to live in a Hampshire
foreign
you can see it as a subsidy a special
super subsidy to the banks for the right
to create money
which should be for the benefit of the
public and spend through a democratic
process
there's also another form of money which
is effectively an electronic version of
cash
and it's a type of money that the
commercial Banks use themselves to make
payments between each other the High
Street Banks don't want to be carrying
around huge quantities of money because
it's dangerous and it's inconvenient and
it's you know expensive you have to hire
security guards for that type of money
so what they do is they pay each other
in what is an electronic version of cash
um which in the industry is known as
Central Bank Reserves
um they keep this electronic cash in
accounts at the bank of England
but as a member of the public you can't
access this electronic cash you can't
get an account with the bank of England
what they do is they they effectively
sell this central bank money to the
banks and they do this by creating it
out of nothing and using this money to
pay for bonds to buy bonds from The High
Street Banks so the High Street bank
will come along with a bond which is you
know effectively government debt and it
will give it to the bank of England and
then return the bank of England will
type some new numbers into the bank's
account at the bank of England so
effectively they're creating Central
Bank Reserves out of nothing the bank of
England creates Central Bank Reserves by
increasing the available credit in the
settlement bank's account with the bank
of England
the settlement Bank in return post bonds
or sales assets as collateral for the
reserves
a total of 46 Banks hold Central Reserve
Accounts at the bank of England
smaller or foreign Banks hold accounts
with one of these 46 Banks to allow them
to accept or make payments in pounds
sterling
prior to March 2009 the bank of England
would ask each of the major settlement
Banks how much Reserve currency they
needed
the settlement Banks would then swap a
bond for the reserve currency
and agree to repurchase the bond for a
specific amount at a specified future
date
the settlement Banks would then receive
interest at base or policy rate for the
Central Bank Reserves they held
since the crisis settlement Bank Central
reserves have shot up dramatically
when Bank customers transfer funds from
their account to another person's
account
a process called intraday clearing
occurs
the amount of central Reserve Currency
Bank a has at the bank of England
is reduced by the corresponding amount
that bank B receives
this is the importance of central
Reserve currency to Banks
before the credit crisis
if a bank was short of central Reserves
at the bank of England to meet its
obligations
then the bank would have to loan
reserves from other banks with interest
if you sell something on eBay you know
that that deal is not complete until you
get some money put into your account you
know most people actually want to see
the money in their account before
they're happy to close on a deal now the
banks are pretty much the same but they
want to see the money in their account
at the bank of England before they
consider a deal complete so for example
if you if you're buying a house from
somebody who banks with a different bank
then what what will happen after you
spent a quarter of a million on a house
is you'll tell your bank to transfer
some money to the house sellers bank and
what the bank will do is actually
instruct the bank of England to move
250 000 from their account at the bank
of England to the bank of the house
seller and that money will actually move
across between the accounts at the bank
of England
um when that money's moved across then
the banks will consider that that
payment has been made you know it's been
settled
um they don't really deal in the kind of
money that we have in our accounts they
deal in this special money that's can
only be used at the central bank
there are millions of people across the
country all transferring money to each
other using only a few major Banks
these Banks can keep a tally on their
computer systems
and usually many of the movements cancel
each other out at the end of the day
the five major Banks RBS Lloyds
HSBC Barclays and Santander
hold over 85 percent of all deposits
as there are a limited number of banks
in the system
the central Reserve money can only be
moved around them in a closed loop
the money is just circulating through
the system over and over again and if
you think about it a one pound coin
could be used to make a billion pounds
of payments if it was circulated a
billion times and that's effectively the
system that you have now is you have a
small pool of real money that's just
going around and around the system and
it's being used to make a huge quantity
of payments on our behalf it's just
before the crisis there was only 20
billion pounds in the accounts at the
central bank
if they don't have enough of this
central bank money then effectively they
can't make payments and if that happens
and pretty quickly the entire system
sees us up so the bank of England has
the responsibility of making sure
there's enough of this money in the
system
the requirements for banks to hold a
specific amount of reserves has changed
many times since 1947.
at that time Banks needed to hold a
minimum ratio of 32 percent of reserves
cash or treasury bonds to deposits
in 2006 the corridor system was
introduced
in which banks could set their own
Reserve targets each month
[Music]
the rules changed again in March 2009
when the bank of England introduced
quantitative easing
quantitative easing in effect gives
settlement Banks the central Reserve
currency for free
the central Reserve currency is what is
referred to as the real money in the
fractional Reserve model
but the fact is Banks can have as much
of this as they want
and Central Reserve currency itself is a
form of Fiat money which is backed by
nothing
as a consequence there is no longer a
meaningful fractional Reserve
[Music]
if you look over the history of the last
150 years or so you start off with the
development of a gold standard that
really comes to four in the 1880s 1890s
where essentially countries pay
themselves to a particular defined value
of gold and then they have an agreement
to fix that value to hold that value
into trade gold amongst themselves to
make sure the balances are all there and
also to try and restrict or expand or
contract activity in their own economies
to make sure that the balance that
particular fixed prices is maintained
that disintegrates in after the first
World War I mean this is where the whole
thing breaks apart very major
dislocation in the international
monetary system at that point not really
resolved until you get Bretton Woods
agreements at the end of the second
world war in which everything is pegged
to the dollar and the dollar is paid to
the gold so you kind of one removed from
gold backing or saying that there is a
definite you know sort of solid
commodity money behind the paper money
and the credit money that we're all
using over here you're kind of one
removed from it
after Hiroshima Tokyo wondered when the
next atom bomb would fall
they did not wander long
[Music]
in 1944
at Bretton Woods
the U.S and the UK began to negotiate
how to govern the world economy the
world monetary system and came up with
the World Bank and the IMF in a series
of other institutions designed to manage
the Global Currency and there was still
a gold standard but this gold standard
was going to be tied to the dollar all
of the world's gold had moved from
London
to Fort Knox
and all of the world's currencies were
tied to the dollar
this system was designed to manage the
sorts of imbalances to avoid credit
crunches or for countries that credit
crunches are known as balance of Trades
deficits I.E when they can't pay their
bills and their currency collapses the
currencies were managed and the system
was stable as long as the Americans
played the role of oversight
now who knows the great story about how
that all came to an end
so the quantity of money that was needed
to pay for the Vietnam War
that's exactly what I was trying to get
at oil shocks was another one that meant
that the Americans were no longer
respecting their role or playing their
role governing the monetary system they
were inflating the value of their own
currency but ostensibly it was meant to
be tied tied to Gold into every other
currency
so what did the French do the French
were a little bit worried that President
Nixon wasn't entirely honest
and they were worried that they were
that precisely what we described
that Nixon was printing money when he
shouldn't have been what's going on and
they were worried there wasn't enough
gold to honor the exchange rate of the
French franc so they
sent a gun boat to New York Harbor to
ever so politely ask for our gold back
please
did they get their gold back
go and guess
they didn't and the Bretton Woods system
came to an end
and this is the point in which we enter
the modern era of the financial system
historically money creation was pegged
to a commodity often gold but today it
is pegged to nothing
which means there is nothing backing our
money
this piece of paper
is just a piece of paper
where does this leave us
if money is based on nothing
why do we think it has any value
sorry
because we can still go and exchange it
what somebody else is going to shout
great little Latin fact the word for
credit comes from
belief
correct
since the collapse of the dollar gold
standard in 1971 and the deregulation of
the financial system
money creation has grown exponentially
the world economic Forum meeting in in
Davos
at the present time have called on a
need for
the credit within the
economy the global economy to be
expanded by
100 trillion dollars 100 trillion US
Dollars uh
trillion is 12 notes so 100 trillion if
you want to imagine is a one followed by
40 knots
they believe this credit expansion will
create a boom because there is now more
money in the economy with which to make
investments
it's fascinating that this the emergence
of digital currencies how it's
transformed everything really because it
just completely Unleashed private Banks
to dominate and create the money system
that works for them and works for the
people who run private Banks
if you want to grow an economy under the
current sale we have to have growing
debt you can't
you know this is something that very
very few people really understand
especially not the politicians who are
managing the economy which is a scary
thought
[Music]
as the money supply grows more money is
available which can be invested in
productive Avenues however it can also
be used to gamble and drive up asset
prices
[Music]
inflation is a rise in the general level
of prices of goods and services in an
economy over a period of time
when the general price level rises
each unit of currency buys fewer goods
and services
as the money supply grows and there is
more currency available more money is
available for investment which can lead
to growth
but more money is also available for
purchases of goods and speculation which
leads to inflation
essentially inflation is what happens
when too much money is chasing too few
goods and services
so that there's too much money for the
the actual output of the economy foreign
years between 2000 and 2007 the money
supply doubled and the banks you know
the Central Bank the bank of England in
this time was under the impression that
they had it under control because they
were saying you know prices aren't going
up that much
of course they were only looking at
prices in you know in your local Corner
Shop they weren't looking at the price
of Housing and housing is you know the
biggest expenditure that most people
will make
increasing house prices
it may may make you feel like you're
you're becoming wealthier but as your
wealth increases the effect is that your
children's wealth is actually decreasing
so in fact there's no net gain in wealth
because your children are going to have
to pay even more
when they want to buy a house so in
effect there's no there's no kind of net
increase they're going to have to earn
even more they're gonna have to go into
even more debt
so the rising house prices do not create
additional net GDP value to the economy
it they actually what they do is they
redistribute wealth
uh towards those people who already have
houses are you wealthier people and
remove it from poor people who can't
afford to get on the housing matter so
it's another example of a very
regressive policy actually to allow
house prices to Simply inflate it makes
everybody feel kind of like things are
going well and people spend more money
on other stuff they take Equity out of
their houses but it it's not creating
new jobs it's not enhancing the quality
of the economy it's not helping our
balance of trade it's not helping the
public deficit it's a it's a zero-sum
game
thank you
as of August 2011
85.5 of consumer Bank lending was
secured as mortgages on dwellings
if you have somebody creating money that
can only be spent on one thing which is
housing then the price of that thing is
going to go up between 2000 and 2010
they created over a trillion pounds of
new money 500 billion pounds just in the
three years before the crisis that's why
house prices went up the way they were
there's nothing you know special about
houses it was just all this funny money
being pumped into that market if money
is spent into the economy
into into a lot of money goes into
houses for example into mortgages
that's an increase in the amount of
money in the economy without a
corresponding increase in activity in
output in GDP it's non-gdp based
spending
that's what causes inflation and and in
the UK we've we've had it in Spades
we've had you know this massive housing
boom
and that the main cause for the housing
boom in my opinion is the huge amount of
speculative credit created by the Banks
to go into houses if houses were cheaper
they would be easier to build more
they'll be more of them would be built
there would be less huge houses with
hardly any people in them London would
not be the center of a kind of very rich
speculative orgy where all the richest
people in the world wants want to get a
property in London because it's seen as
a great asset you know houses would be
seen as places to live primarily rather
than places to invest
important thing to think about is if
you're a bank
and you've got to make a loan
you have choices you can you can give
that lane to a small business
and you'll know that the risk to you of
that loan failing defaulting is actually
quite High because that small business
the owners of that business have limited
liability which means if the business
goes bust
you as a bank are getting nothing back
essentially you know that that's it so
that's kind of high risk compared to
loaning your money to somebody with some
collateral with a house behind them like
a mortgage so there's a there's a kind
of simple incentive for banks to prefer
putting money into housing then into a
small business now that's a real problem
or if you if you if you widen that out
across a whole economy because it means
there's an incentive you know to put
money into speculative rather than
productive investment so again we have
to think about how we create a monetary
system that is more balanced between
those two kinds of speculative and
productive investment the government's
showing very little uh enormous
reluctance to regulate the housing
market and to again regulate the amount
of money that that Banks put into houses
we don't decide who creates credit for
what no we leave that to a couple of
chaps in the bank to decide basically
foreign
occurs when there is very high inflation
in the price of a specific good or
service over a short period of time
the idea of the Tulips and their
relevance is that we saw the first ever
Financial bubble and crash
The Craze for tulips black tulips being
a mythical ideal of what somebody could
genetically engineered through
cultivation after many generations
became a Mania in the Netherlands in the
1630s what they didn't realize was that
many of the very very rare patterns on
tulips were caused by a virus and
weren't genetic at all
but they traded them to the extent that
tulip bulbs got to the point where they
were worth 10 times the average annual
salary
of a person working in the Netherlands
there was a Futures Market in tulip
bulbs because obviously you plant them
now but you don't know what's going to
come out the ground so we see already
400 years ago the Armani system or a
financial system is not something that
exists in the abstract Somewhere Out
There In The Ether but something that
was to do with States power trade and
how they interact with each other
unlike tulips which are a disposable
luxury
houses are both a necessity and a luxury
and as such they are ideal as a vehicle
for money and bubble creation
a dwelling is perhaps the most prized
possession of value most people aspire
to
inflating house prices in this way
allows the nation to expand its money
supply without affecting inflation data
the additional purchasing power created
increases the perceived wealth in
relation to other nations
and thus it creates relative power
it is a way of increasing monetary power
without investing in the productive
growth of Industry
but certainly if you look at Britain and
America's outstanding examples of this
these are countries with very high rates
of private homeownership so you've got a
good base to try and perform this sort
of policy off the back of I think was
quite deliberate in the case of the US
almost explicit is Alan Greenspan is
head of the Federal Reserve when
confronted by a stock market crash at
the end of the the 1990s quite
deliberately slashed interest rates to
almost zero everyone can borrow very
very cheaply in particular it's very
easy to borrow against a house because
this is an asset and it's potentially
something that a bank can say well okay
we're not just lending you money
unsecured you actually do have a house
and that's great because we can
repossess it they won't tell you this
when you take the mortgage but they can
do this and that bubble is in what fuels
expansion such as it is inside the US
and inside the UK where something
similar takes place for the next decade
or so I think it's also a reflection of
an underlying weakness of these
governments that they they simply like
the will and possibly the ability but I
think it more comes down to a will to
challenge financial markets to challenge
big capital and say we're going to do
something different now and you're going
to have to go along with it because
we've been democratically elected and
new law frankly haven't and we have a
mandate to do this and we're going to
make this happen you have to remember
it's all part of the plan
in Holland or in the Netherlands what we
had over a period of trying to get
independence initially from Spain and
trying to raise money to get an army to
free themselves was Financial Innovation
they innovated public lotteries to get
money together they had public
subscription this was the idea that led
to the idea of public shares a piece of
the action that anybody could invest in
that meant that something like
two-thirds of the population was
investing in tulip bulbs by the 1630s
after Independence these these
instruments were applied to financing
expansion why was such a small country
able to hold its own against so much
bigger countries for example Spain and
Portugal that had the benefits of their
Empires for over a century
in respect of the Netherlands why could
they compete on what resource basis well
they had a more efficient a more
involved and a broader based Financial
system with these instruments that
they'd innovated that allowed them to
bring more money to bear at one point
than anybody else more quickly
incredible
but true
now inflation can be avoided
if the amount of money that goes into
the economy
is regulated in a way that it doesn't
exceed the actual activity that's
happening in the economy now the best
way to do that in my opinion is to make
sure that money is issued into the
economy only for productive investment
for productive goods and services so
money goes in to help a small business
start up which creates jobs which
creates additional purchasing power
which means there's no inflation
during their history almost all central
banks have employed forms of direct
credit regulation
the central bank would determine desired
nominal GDP growth
then calculate the necessary amount of
credit creation to achieve this
and then allocate this credit creation
both across the various Banks and type
of Banks and across industrial sectors
unproductive credit was suppressed
thus it was difficult or impossible to
obtain Bank credit for large-scale
purely speculative transactions such as
today's large-scale Bank funding to
hedge funds
the World Bank recognized in a 1993
study that this mechanism of
intervention in credit allocation was at
the core of the East Asian economic
miracle there's all sorts of things that
governments have done in the past very
successfully in a number of cases and
not often not unsuccessfully in this
country but yeah the examples that
spring to mind like South Korea Japan
often any stages where government's been
quite targeted about how they're going
to rebalance the economy picking sectors
and deciding where the investment should
take place I think that has to start to
happen in the UK because we're in a
demand side recession rather than
looking at crisis of Supply you have to
have a system where credit is put into
productive
Avenues where credit is put into
building High-Speed Rail links where
credit is put into building houses
rather than giving people money to
inflate the price of of houses so it's
it's quite simple really in that way
um and uh the current system is simply
set up not to do that basically
the creation of money by private banks
for non-productive usage causes real
inflation and as such it is attacks on
the purchasing power of the medium of
Exchange
the figures for UK are quite Stark
actually that
average median real incomes for so
that's you know what bit in the middle
for most people declined over the last
eight years also they're now in quite
sharp decliners as we go into the
recession I mean the sharp bits really
since it looks like since about the
1930s put it that way so real incomes
are declining
Bank created fiat currency allows the
private Banks to suck wealth from the
economy and over time results in a
gradual decrease in the standard of
living
as people become poorer they become even
more dependent on debt
and this at a time when efficiency and
machination have improved dramatically
if you know you go back to the 1960s and
we were expected to to we're looking
forward to an age of leisure what would
be what they were talking television
programs saying what people can do with
all their spare time
you know and now we've got more people
working harder than ever
spending more than ever
which looks great you know when spending
more everyone says oh yeah you know but
if you're not actually benefiting from
what you're spending if you're having to
spend the money on child care costs on
commuting costs you know and so forth uh
just you know the costs that people
didn't in the past used to have to pay
because you know you could walk to work
and you know one member of the family
remain was able to stay at home and be a
permanent Homemaker then you know she'd
make sure you're not actually any better
off
you know everyone's under and then
everyone's under such enormous pressures
nowadays you know I am conscious that to
say my four nephews and nieces are
facing difficult times
she's going to find themselves having to
work
you know
um
very hard just to keep just to keep a
roof over them just to get a roof over
there just keep a rope over their head
people are getting poorer in real terms
it's because prices are always going up
because all this new funny money is
being pumped into the system by the
Banks
and they're creating it all as debt so
at the same time as prices are going up
and things are getting more expensive
we're getting further and further into
debt and you know our our wealth and the
return that we get from actually working
is getting less and less all the time
when you can't deal with poverty when
you have a financial system and a money
system that distributes money from the
poor to the very rich
any distribution that you try and do in
the opposite direction is
um you know it's effectively pressing in
the wind if you look at issues like you
know increasing inequality one obvious
way to tackle inequality is to have say
for example a redistributive tax system
you know you tax the rich you give some
money to the poor you move a bit of
money down down the scale
um that's all very well but if you
completely Overlook the fact that
there's another redistributive system
which is taking money from the poor and
giving it to the rich then you're not
really going to tackle this inequality
and
um the way a debt-based money system
works it guarantees that for every pound
of money there's going to be a pound of
debt now that debt is typically going to
end up with you know the poor uh the
sort of lower middle classes those
people end up with the debt and they end
up paying interest on that money which
then goes back to the banking sector and
gets distributed to the people working
in the city or in Wall Street
um and what this what this system does
overall is it distributes money from
from the poor to the rich essentially
distributes money from you know the
poorer regions of the UK back to the
city of London and it also distributes
money from all the small businesses you
know all the little factories around the
UK and distributes that money back into
the bank financial sector we have a
system whereby the activity of actually
supplying occurs under the very same
roof as the same organization that's
responsible for profiting from putting
together borrowers and lenders are you a
bank
so a bank
creates our nation's money supply as
well as making loans for profit the
government cannot allow the banking
system to fail
because if it did
over 97 of all money would disappear
this is why in the event of a crisis the
risk is transferred to the taxpayer
but even during normal times Banks
receive numerous guarantees and benefits
beyond the right to create money Bill by
the way I know the Bank of America is a
very big bank it happens I've got 32
there myself and just between us what
Assurance do I have that this money is
safe
well uh all deposits up to ten thousand
dollars are assured or insured by the
federal government in Washington that's
my guarantee yes have you heard that the
federal government is about 280 billion
dollars in the hole
[Applause]
foreign
Banks receive large safety nets from the
government
the taxpayer guarantees 85 000 pounds as
Deposit Insurance
and the bank of England provides
liquidity Insurance in case a bank runs
out of Reserve currency
someone wrote that a big Investment Bank
is like a giant vampire squid wrapped
around the face of humanity
hypnotizing politicians who throw money
at the banks no strings attached no
matter what damage is done
trashing the planet
forcing cuts to think make life better
goodbye schools goodbye playgrounds
goodbye jobs
the bankers that we bailed out then gave
themselves bonuses that were bigger than
the first wave of public spending cuts
Britain alone gave the banks more money
than it cost to put a man on the moon
six times over
where did our money go who let the banks
get away with it why
can vampire squids ever be useful
no government yet is brave enough to
tame them
perhaps they need a plan
thank you
the spending cuts agenda is an attempt
by the government to shift debt from its
account to that of the public
this is the government's response to the
bank bailouts and is necessary in a
debt-based monetary system
where increased purchasing power is the
result of growing debt
and where a diversification of debt
provides overall stability and Market
confidence
policies such as student fee increases
in the privatization of Public Services
assets and Industry follow the same
model
the problem we're facing I think is that
uh there's been there's this
transference from the public debt to the
private debt which is a which is
essentially a way of transferring risk
actually away from sort of UK PLC and
the government on to the the heads of
individuals and it's going to be the
most vulnerable individuals who are
going to have the most debt thus it's a
very unprogressive regressive uh policy
framework that the government's
embarking on where the risk is moved on
to those who are most vulnerable and if
there is another Financial shock if
there's an oil shock for example the
people who will pay the penalty or those
are the poorest people in society or
homeowners for example who will fall
into negative equity if interest rates
go up even one or two percent uh they'll
be real really big problems so I don't
think it's a sensible Way Forward at the
moment at all and it's it's regressive
and it's certainly not fair in the terms
that um that the government's talk about
and it's certainly not a case of we're
in this together
as more of a kind
of as a result more money is created and
there is a boom
some private Equity companies have taken
this Theory to the extreme
engaging in a practice known as a
leveraged buyout
where a company is purchased at an often
inflated price and the purchase price is
transferred to the business as a debt
the company becomes responsible for the
funding of its own purchase
these debts are often so great that the
company needs to reduce staff salaries
and research activities
when you have to factor interest as a
business if you have to factor interest
repayment into your goods and services
then you have to charge a perpetually
higher price as you take on more and
more debt
an increase in the diversification of
debt results in an increase in the money
supply
when the money supply increases more
money is available for productive
activities and consumption
which is the condition for a boom
it's questionable whether we're going to
get out of this recession or whether
we'll just keep taking along the way
that we are now
um however if we do then when we come
out of this recession when growth starts
again look at what happens to debt it
will rise and it will keep rising and
the faster the economy is growing the
faster the debt will rise and then give
it another three to five years we'll be
back where we were you know the debt
will become too much people start
defaulting again
um it's kind of the system that we're
locked into now is we can't we can't
grow the economy without growing the
debt and the debt is the very thing that
will bring down the economy the only
option going forwards is to reform it to
stop Banks from creating money as debt
by fixing the monetary system we can
prevent the banks from ever causing
another financial crisis and we can also
make the the current you know Public
Service cuts and the tax Rises and the
increase in national debt are necessary
the current monetary system allows the
banking sector to extract wealth from
the economy whilst providing nothing
productive in return
I mean why is it that we've got all this
technology
um you know all this new efficiency and
yeah it now requires two people to
finance a household whereas in the 50s
it only needed one person working and
the reason for that is not because you
know these washing machines and
everything are more expensive it's
because of all the debt and it's because
you know effectively the banking sector
is creaming It Off from everybody else
so a growing banking sector isn't a sign
you know it's not a good thing if the
banking sector is growing it's either
that it's becoming less efficient or
it's becoming a parasite on the rest of
the economy and that's you know we can
talk about the banking sector becoming
four percent five percent six percent of
GDP
what's happening to the rest of the
economy it's becoming 96 95 94 of GDP
we've got to get switched on to this now
you know if we want to if we want to
have a chance of tackling any of the
other big social issues you've got to
figure out the money issue
the poorest in the world pay for crises
even when they've not benefited from the
um the the often Reckless and
speculative booms like the housing boom
in in Ireland that preceded
um that crisis you know over the last 30
years we've seen
um income differentials increase so that
the rich have got much much richer and
Ordinary People haven't they've stayed
the same or they've they've got poorer
and one of the ways that the economy was
kept going was by providing cheap credit
was provide providing debt to those very
people who couldn't really afford things
anymore and so they kept buying and when
it collapses it's those same people that
they have to pay once again even though
in in many ways they were the victims
the first time around
as a result of the crises the bank of
England has bought corporate debt and
repackaged it at lower rates of Interest
yet the average person is being asked to
pay more than ever to borrow on
overdrafts and credit cards
depths between the very wealthy
um or between governments can always be
renegotiated and always have been
throughout world history there are not
anything set in stone it's generally
speaking when you have debts owed by the
poor to the Rifts that suddenly deaths
become a sacred obligation more
important than anything else the idea of
renegotiatingly becomes unthinkable
thank you
can you pin down exactly what would keep
investors happy make them feel more
confident
that's a tough one
personally it doesn't matter that that's
it I'm a Trader I don't really care
about that
[Music]
if I see an opportunity to make money I
go with that so for most Traders we
don't really care that much how they're
going to fix the how they're going to
fix the economy how they're going to fix
the uh the whole situation our job is to
make money from it and personally I've
been dreaming of this one for three
years
if you know what to do you can make a
lot of money from this I I had a
confession which is I go to bed every
night I dream of another recession I
dream of another Moment Like This
I dream of another recession I dream of
another Moment Like This
you can make a lot of money from this
[Applause]
[Music]
way which you can look across Europe now
and see that the new prime minister
Greece Not Elected essentially impose
papademost former employee of Goldman
Sachs the new prime minister and Finance
Minister of Italy Mario Monty former
employee of Goldman Sykes the new
president of the European Central Bank
former employee of Goldman Sachs it's
quite you know you kind of see these
people popping up absolutely everywhere
that's the way to change what we have
take all power and all freedoms away
from the people and collect everything
into the hands of one small group with
absolute power
from the people
without the people
against the people what's been
interesting out of all this I suppose is
the question of democracy that's been
opened up very starkly in Europe that
you have a government bank because they
essentially imposed on you it's Bankers
who more or less got us into this mess
to put it rather crudely but that's a
good first approximation to it and then
you say okay Bankers are the people who
therefore gonna get us out of here and
incidentally they're going to run your
country now there's a serious question
democracy that's opened up here by the
way the banking crisis drove more than a
hundred million people back into poverty
the mortality statistics of people who
go into poverty rise hugely for a whole
range of reasons so the banking crisis
isn't just about becoming poor it was
about killing people as well
and guess what
we haven't really got to the bottom of
it we never held anybody to account and
we haven't done the radical reforming
job that we really needed to do because
we mistakenly thought
if we destabilize the position any
further it'll make matters worse and
guess you took the decisions all the
people who were there in the first place
no that the business of one of these
businessmen is murder
their weapons are modern
they are thinking 2
000 years out of date
look I was there when the secretary and
the chairman of Federal Reserve came
those days and talked with members of
Congress about what was going on it was
about September 15th here's the facts
and we don't even talk about these
things on Thursday at about 11 o'clock
in the morning the Federal Reserve
noticed a tremendous drawdown of uh uh
uh money market accounts in the United
States to the tune of
550 billion dollars was being drawn out
in a matter of an hour or two the
treasury opened up its uh a window to
help they pumped 105 billion dollars in
the system and quickly realized that
they could not stem the tide we were
having an electronic run on the banks
they decided to close the operation
close down the money accounts and
announce a guarantee of 250 thousand
dollars per per account so there
wouldn't be further Panic out there and
that's what actually happened if they
had not done that their estimation was
that by two o'clock that afternoon five
and a half trillion dollars would have
been drawn out of the money market
system of the United States would have
collapsed the entire economy of the
United States and within 24 hours the
world economy would have collapsed
[Music]
when money is withdrawn internationally
from one currency to another
the reserve currency shifts from the
National Bank of one country
to the reserve account of the foreign
Bank
foreign banks have relationships with
local banks that allow them to hold
foreign Reserve currencies whilst not
being a part of the Central Bank scheme
at the local Central Bank
for example
when one thousand pounds is transferred
into Euros
a UK bank will agree an exchange rate
with a Euro Area Bank
perhaps 1.15 Euros to the pound
the UK bank will then transfer a
thousand pounds of the central Reserve
currency to the UK partner Bank of the
European Bank
whilst the European bank will transfer
1150 Euros of Reserve currency to the
European partner Bank of the UK bank
what happens when currencies and the
exchange rate system is no longer
managed what are some of the first
consequences
the evaluations
speculation
imbalances where some countries would
accrue more and more and more what what
would they accrue
other currencies
other currencies
the reserve currency needs to be spent
in the country of origin
or exchanged into other currencies
most foreign Banks do not have deposit
taking accounts outside of their
National borders and as such the foreign
reserves they hold do not come back to
them in the form of deposits
when a country accumulates trade
imbalances it either accumulates foreign
Reserve currencies in the case of
surplus
or spends its own Reserves in the case
of negative trade balances
balance of Traders is basically uh the
difference between what you're selling
abroad and what you're buying from
abroad now the feature on the the UK is
that for a very long period of time it's
had a deficit on something called a
visible balance of trade which is
trading things about things that you can
see so that is Goods that you'd
recognize stuff you can put in
containers it's cars computers things
that you'd see in a shop that's been in
substantial deficit for I think it
opened up in in the uh it did open up in
the early 1980s and essentially it
hasn't it hasn't gone away since and if
anything has got wider and wider
foreign exchange reserves cannot be
directly used for domestic spending
the money can only be spent abroad
or on Imports
a country with a large balance of trade
deficit
relies on its creditors to spend the
imbalances accrued in its own Market
without the having proposals in the past
to try and create a mechanism for those
imbalances to to match up
so Keynes for instance John Maynard
Keynes at the end of the second world
war his original proposal for what
became Breton Woods in the set of
Institutions settled there like the IMF
and the World Bank was that there will
be a kind of international clearing
Union this is particularly relating to
the trade site rather than the sort of
the financial side directly but the
principle was that you know once trade
balances had opened up everybody would
bang through an international clearing
bank and that's would kind of force
everyone to eventually reconcile the
imbalances that appeared in the real
economy
but no such mechanism exists
the accumulated net trade imbalance for
the UK is around 800 billion pounds
in essence what has happened is that
over many years some countries have had
big trade surpluses and others big trade
deficits the countries with trade
deficits have been spending more than
they've been earning so they've had to
borrow from abroad and they've been
doing this year after year
countries like that to the United States
ourselves and some other countries in
Europe that cannot go on
and there are two ways in which this can
come to an end either and we're seeing
this in some other countries in Europe
if they can't find new ways to become
competitive then their ability to repay
the debts is called into question
another way of doing it which we
followed is that we've got a credible
plan to repay our debts and the value of
sterling has fallen by 25 to make our
exports more competitive and attractive
to overseas buyers and it to be more
attractive for British consumers to buy
from British producers rather than
overseas producers that is what we have
done to put in place a framework to
rebalance our economy and I'm sure
that's the right way to do it
currency War also known as competitive
devaluation is a condition where
countries compete against each other to
achieve a relatively low exchange rate
for their currency
as the price to buy a particular
currency Falls
so too does the real price of exports
from that country
domestic industry receives a boost in
demand both at home and abroad
it's made British exports appear rather
cheaper so they've kind of recovered a
little bit but because the rest of the
world is now looking really quite repeat
they've started to fall back down again
so what we're looking at is something
that
we can almost uh kind of Anarchy and in
a way the increasing everything this is
what's happened over the last few years
where even Brazilian Finance Minister
has been most vocal about this uh
talking about currency Wars talking
about the desire of national governments
when confronted by a major recession
they think if we could export more we
could dig ourselves out of this
recession if we want to export more we
depreciate our currency that makes all
Goods cheaper everyone else buys them
we'll all be better off now the issue
here is if you depreciate it's like
everybody else appreciates against you
their stuff becomes more expensive so
they're not too happy about that they
also want to depreciate this is where
you can see a competitive rounded
evaluations breaking out
to decrease the value of its National
currency
a national Central Bank sells Reserve
currency into the market
it creates this currency out of nothing
by typing numbers into a computer
[Music]
during the long phase of commodity money
the exchange rate would depend on the
amount of gold silver or copper
contained in the coins of each country
similarly after the Advent of paper
money and the gold standard
the exchange rate depended on the amount
of gold the government promised to pay
the holder of the banknotes these
amounts did not vary greatly in the
short term
and as such exchange rates between
currencies were relatively stable
after the second world war currencies
were pegged to the dollar
and the dollar was backed by gold
this system came to an end in 1971. so
we have a modern Financial system where
money
is now chaotically organized there is no
exchange rate because there's no gold
standard system to sustain so we don't
need it in fact we believe the market
will resolve all of the problems of
exchange whether your currency should be
worth more than mine is a reflection of
your economy relative to mine and if
that changes the currency and the
exchange rate can change and if we need
that to happen it'll happen magically by
the efficiency of market and profit
seeking and you guys know the rest I
think
a currency's value in relation to
another currency is determined by the
market
if more people want to buy a currency
then sell it its value increases
if more people want to sell
its value decreases
the value is set by individual Banks as
they buy and sell currencies they will
adjust the exchange rate
in the last study I read in 2007
each day on currency markets 3.2
trillion dollars are traded each day
who knows what the global GDP is
50. again Brucie higher
60 that's closer the point is think
about that exchange happening every
single day there's about 260 business
days a year
it takes a few weeks to match the global
value of every economic transaction that
happens everywhere every day in a year
and it takes a few weeks obviously all
of us Trade Currency and fairly
regularly if you go abroad you exchange
into another currency that's a form of
currency trading you're swapping your
pounds into whatever Euros or Yen or
whatever it might be that happens fairly
regularly and that's a conventional part
of the trading process you know large
corporations have to do this on a
regular basis where it becomes something
that people question and where you get
people saying well hang on this is
speculation is when you get people
realizing that currencies move around
next to each other and if they move
around in value next to each other
there's always an opportunity to try and
make money out of those changes in value
and therefore you can speculate on it
and that's that's the more sort of
questionable end of the market that's
the bit of the market that things like a
financial transactions tax would try and
chop away at because the Assumption
there and it's it's kind of not
incorrect is that this just produces
instability for everyone else that these
people want volatility in the market
because that's how they make their money
they want to encourage it and they do
encourage it by trading and speculating
in the way that they do
by 2010
the Foreign Exchange Market had grown to
be the largest and most liquid Market in
the world
with an average of four trillion dollars
of currency being exchanged every day
volatility creates a need what does it
do to countries especially perhaps small
ones like developing countries if there
are suddenly huge and instantly
fluctuating Financial flow what do they
have to do to cope
production of the products that they're
selling increase their production and
sell more
lowering the price
and becoming possibly even poor once you
start to we met the International System
it becomes really quite a peculiar uh
quite peculiar thing in that a lot of it
depends on simply sentiment and beliefs
about what an economy is like rather
more than depends on anything the
economy might or might not actually be
doing and that can shift very very
rapidly because you know if it's just
somebody's belief about currency is
supportable uh then you know they can
carry and believe in this until well to
whatever if that belief changes and can
change very rapidly in a financial
Market the process of financial
contagion can can take place you know in
just minutes seconds even that you can
just move from being apparently quite a
stable robust economy to being one that
suddenly sentiment is turned against you
and you find that markets are picking on
you and it can often be not much more
than you're simply the next door
neighbor of uh you know a country that's
currently in trouble
many of the world's Financial crises in
the past 30 years have been caused by
rapid withdrawals of the nation's
currency
or the currencies of an entire region
this type of activity is often referred
to as Financial Warfare
it's benefited
major institutions really quite
substantially the Goldman Sachs for
example or any large bank has done
somewhat better out of this set of
Arrangements that it would have done in
a far more regulated environment so it's
made people very very wealthy it's
allowed financial markets to expand
absolutely enormously anybody involved
in that is Keen on seeing a deregulated
world in the case of the UK you have a
government which has been quite overtly
and deliberately and aggressively
arguing against any forms of Regulation
being imposed on those financial markets
but it's not the case that someone's
behind the scenes pulling the strings
it's it's the this is this is how the
thing works quite deliberately quite you
know overtly in front of you that's the
world as it is it's making some people
very rich they're quite happy with it
I think it is a form of economic Warfare
um much of the the change in the in the
way that the global economy works over
the last 30 years result from this this
debt this third world debt because it's
given rich countries and Banks and the
financial sector enormous amounts of
power and control over the poorer bits
of the world where a lot of the
resources are that we like using and
that's been used in a way that many
people have compared to a form of
colonialism it's a very real direct form
of of power that's been used over those
countries to force those countries to do
what are really in the interests of the
richest segments of the world that they
do and as a result of that not only have
corporations become absolutely uh in
very you know made huge amounts of
profits and become absolutely enormous
and and all pervasive but the financial
sector has become even bigger than that
and the and the real money in in the
world to be made today is not by
producing anything at all it's simply by
forms of speculating basically making
money from money that's the most
profitable and and by Far and Away
um the the biggest form of of activity
of economic activity that exists in the
world today
to protect themselves vulnerable
countries need to accrue currency from
rich countries
who create these currencies out of
nothing
the Netherlands first governor general
of Indonesia the man who built the trade
routes fortified them what I mean by
that is built forts along them and
fought Spanish fleets and British fleets
said about the development of the spa of
the of the Netherlands Empire and
Netherlands trade
was we cannot make trade without War nor
War without trade
money and power
so reserves have become the way in which
you can insure yourself against what
speculation who you said speculation
speculative attack
fall in the markets
bubbles
when a country succumbs to a speculative
attack it is asked to deregulate its
markets and conform its Financial system
to that of the dominant party
the big problem that's faced by most
developing countries who got into a debt
crisis was that they were told by the
powers that be in the world the
international monetary fund which is in
many ways governs the the Global
Financial system that the way to get out
of debt actually is first of all to to
restructure your economy especially to
increase your export so you're earning
more more dollars and then you can pay
off your your debt which is normally in
dollars or some other uh foreign
currency unfortunately time and time
again that was proved to to not be the
case at all actually countries cut back
their public spending to the Bone so
they stopped growing they stopped having
any potential for growth and what they
did produce was was
um was aimed at the export Market was
aimed at creating dollars and so on so
they were paying off their debts but
they weren't uh developing their own
economy at all they were paying far far
more in debt repayments than they were
spending on health or education or
anything else and their debts just kept
getting bigger and bigger and bigger
the country becomes a vassal state
allowing large corporations to exploit
its natural resources and Workforce
it's not it's not even shadowy you see
there's no great mystery about about
what's happening here and about the way
the world operates it's like it's it's
quite blunt I mean for the last 30 years
you've got something pretty much
everywhere it certainly spreads pretty
much everywhere that generally gets
labeled neoliberalism this idea that you
should have floating exchange rates you
know weak regulation particularly
financial markets minimal government
interference or involvement with what
Market does and that's that's more or
less how the world operates and then
there are institutions and the
outstanding one at this point is the IMF
that they will actively try and enforce
this state of affairs so it's not
greatly shadowing if you see what I mean
that there are people behind the scenes
somewhere trying to manipulate stuff is
actually this is quite this is quite
advert this this is happening and this
is how uh for my entire adult life
actually is what it starts to look like
this is how the world of the world is
operated and it's made some people very
very wealthy it's produced enormous
concentrations of wealth so when the
international monetary fund comes in in
order to try and alleviate a countries
debt problems it imposes a set of
conditions and in the 1980s and 90s they
call that set of conditions structural
adjustment structural adjustment program
and it tends to take very similar forms
wherever it happens and indeed we can
see structural adjustment programs in
essence happening today in countries
like Greece and Portugal and Ireland
where countries are instructed to
decrease the amount that they spend on
the public sector
they are instructed to liberalize their
their trade market and liberalize their
Capital markets so money can much more
easily come in and out of their economy
and the idea is that this will encourage
investment to come in from richer parts
of the world and that all of their
problems will be solved from this
investment and in actual fact this has
proved time and time again to be
completely without foundation in actual
fact what happens is it destroys
fledgling Industries and capacities in
these developing countries and
developing countries become completely
dependent on goods and services from
developed countries and also from
capital from developed countries one of
the things the international monetary
fund is very is very keen on is telling
countries to lower the taxes that should
be paid by multinational corporations
when they come and operate in a country
because then you'll encourage more
multinational corporations to come in of
course what it also means is the profits
that are made by those multinational
corporations leave the country just as
quickly and the country itself doesn't
benefit and today you have many
developing countries which have got
almost no tax base they've not developed
a tax base at all and so they're even
more dependent on International Capital
markets on the money markets on creating
debt and that's why you have so many
countries in the world that have really
been robbed of their sovereignty it's
very difficult to see how Democratic
societies can evolve or function when
actually a government is more dependent
on the dictats of the international
monetary fund and the money markets then
it is on their own people
what we've seen since the 1970s is a
dramatic increase in a series of
phenomena that have had a series a
stimulative effect on the changes in the
financial system that have brought us to
the gleaming shining metal in Steel
business that's over there in case you
don't know that's the city of London I'm
putting it
to compensate for the lack of a defined
commodity-based value underlying
currencies financial institutions
developed securitization
as a means to manage risk
develop securitization as a means to try
and stabilize the whole system this is a
set of financial processes and financial
innovations that really Accelerate from
the 70s 80s onwards you had a chaotic
system that needed to manage risk and
you had to innovate you needed
derivatives options Futures you have new
markets in volatility management tools
who knows what the term hedging is
spreading your risk managing your risk
ensuring against your risk precisely
up until very recently you know there's
up until the 1960s the Securities and
Exchange Commission would be quite clear
that you know derivatives that weren't
based on real products like agricultural
products so pork belly futures or
whatever would in fact be essentially
kind of gambling and therefore you
weren't allowed to trade them that and
that changes in the 60s and everybody
can trade you know
currency Futures things that are not
based on real products being traded at
some point in the future but are based
on movements of currency prices
once you have the system of fixed
exchange rate breaks down obviously this
thing accelerates enormously so as you
get the roll back of government
regulation here you get the market
taking over with its own products here
and the theory is that the Market's
better at regulating itself it's more
stable than if you have a government
interfering all the time the efficient
markets hypothesis the idea that you
know you set up a financial Market
they're fast everybody in them is well
informed they all keep a very careful
eye on what everyone else is doing
you'll therefore uh be very stable and
it reflects real changes in the economy
it's not going to be driven by you know
panics and manias and speakers in
bubbles nothing that's really going to
happen if there is movement up and down
it's because something real is happening
and in Traders and investors in the
financial Market responding to it so
that's the efficient markets hypothesis
the practice I think what you see in
2008 is the kind of end of that process
the appearance of this crisis so major
the the belief that it will simply be
self-stabilizing and self-regulating
really can't carry on I mean the
practice Carries On anyway but you can't
really argue in the same way you used to
that it's good or it's necessary or this
is okay for the world
in the last decade we had a new
innovation something called the credit
default swap a way of buying insurance
against the company you've invested in
going bus
and in 2002 they were less worth in
total less than a trillion dollars in
2007 they were worth 60 trillion dollars
that's five years
everybody's suddenly sitting down
thinking oh these cdos we've made don't
in fact provide the kind of stability
that we thought the maths that's inside
of the risk is complete nonsense it
turns out there's far more risk attached
to
um trying to securitize risk and
securitize debt in the way that we have
done this than we thought and we think
these things now worthless
the attempt to get more and more complex
ways of regulating and shaping a
financial markets and trying to make a
quick Buck out of it as well actually
help produce the the opposite effect of
what its kind of apologist said which is
that it led to led to a spectacular
crash
what we saw
result of this very different
phenomenon
above all one sector above all grew and
that was the financial sector
while the financial sector benefits
enormously from the current monetary
system the system is neither stable nor
fair the assumption
in what the bank of England does right
now is that the cash that we hold is
backed up by government debt the
government can back up as Promises by
the fact that it can tax the public
so what they're implying is that cash is
backed up by government debt When
government debt is backed up by the
ability of government to get cash from
the public time and time again over the
last 30 years we've seen private debts
being transformed into into public debts
and the ultimately the price of that
debt is paid by by the public in the in
the debtor country
this is why spending cuts are necessary
the system is designed to make certain
people very rich at the expense of a
nation's citizens and taxpayers
the system lowers the standard of living
of the majority
and distributes this wealth among the
privileged
so what we're left with is a financial
System since the early 70s that has no
fixed exchange rates that suddenly has
increasingly open Financial borders
that has central banks having to manage
without having any control because
there's
nothing here where the gold used to be
chaotically they have to ease
quantitatively they have to lend as a
lender of Last Resort
throughout history monetary systems were
designed to give the dominant
international power
an advantage
and this power is fiercely defended and
expanded on
foreign
a new kind of currency that is backed by
something that that is scarce and that
we really need and we really value
something like energy or renewable
energy for example so a sort of kilowatt
hour backed currency would be would be
very interesting to me we need to start
valuing the things that are most scarce
and and that we need to survive as a
human race in the long run and backing
an international currency with something
like that will generate enormous
investment in for example renewable
energy
if that's the you know the primary
International
unit of account that's that's that's
being used another option is is a basket
of of currencies so you you know you you
mix up the value of of different
currencies
um to create a very solid currency that
people have confidence in
it's even better
with which to back up International
currencies
now if it was possible internationally
some way or another to get all these
competing and increasingly competing
National economies together and say
we're all going to sit down and write
out an agreement somewhere like the
Bretton Woods agreement which will allow
for unlike Breton woods and allow for
you know some currencies to to be pegged
against different baskets of goods that
are more appropriate to their National
economies and you can sort of arrange
this if you could arrange that to happen
then that would be nice and you can see
how that would start to create a kind of
order in the international macro economy
which is otherwise lacking the real
difficulty there is just political is
that who on Earth is going to do this
who is the force that's going to kind of
make this thing happen
creating a monetary system which is both
fair and stable is possible and can be
achieved
what are international organizations for
if not for such a purpose
[Music]
this is George
George worked in a big Bank in the city
of London
but one day without warning George's
bank went bus
luckily the government rescued the bank
and George kept his job but the greedy
government wanted something in return
for their help
they demanded a higher tax on George's
salary and bonus for someone with a
high-cost lifestyle like George a shop
like this can be devastating
[Music]
now George struggles to afford the rent
on his Riverside apartment in central
London the tires on his Aston Martin are
wearing thin and a barely road legal
unless George's situation improves or
unless someone like you helps him and
George may even be forced to walk past
the next several rotailers and buy his
suit from Topshop or next
even if George had anything to celebrate
he can no longer afford the champagne to
celebrate with
George is not alone
[Music]
unless others are suffering like him and
no one knows how long it'll be until the
good times return
[Music]
help George can turn his life around
a simple monthly donation from you can
bring a bit of sunshine back to George's
life
just 395 pounds will help him celebrate
minor achievements with a magnum of
Cristal Champagne as little as 900
pounds will help George buy a new set of
tires for his Aston Martin two thousand
pounds can help George recover his
self-esteem with a suit from a
prestigious Saddle road table
but even a small amount will help
just 200 pounds pound will buy a meal
for George and his girlfriend experience
just 200 pounds extra will buy the
drinks by adopting a banker you won't
just be supporting someone like George
in a time of need you'll also be
supporting the trendy wine bars of the
city of London the luxury car makers of
Italy and the tailors of Savile Row
you'll be doing your patriotic duty to
support Britain's greatest industry in
its time of need
and when the good times return and
George gets his bonus back the taxes he
pays will help fund the public services
that the rest of you scroungers depend
on so please until the good times return
for George and those like him when you
give today
[Music]